aber sie sprechen die kinder an und das
wusste man ja ganz genau dass sie erst
mal nicht geimpft werden können jetzt
sind wir hier in berlin die situation
die kinder werden quasi vom öffentlichen
leben ausgesperrt zweig soll
durchgesetzt werden kinder unter zwölf
können nicht geimpft werden warum lassen
wir die kinder so im stich also da in
der da finde ich in der tat das wären
ministerpräsidenten beschluss bei der 3g
regel schon gesagt haben wir haben ein
sehr intensives test regime jahr an den
schulen für alle schüler und insofern
haben wir da eigentlich schon gesagt
dass schüler im grunde genommen von den
beschränkungen ausgenommen werden sollen
weil wir auch gerade sehen dass zwei
drei wochen nach dem schulbeginn sich in
vielen bundesländern die zahlen
stabilisieren und insofern
finde ich auch gerade diesen punkt dass
kinder an vielen stellen der zugang
verwehrt ist er kritisch lassen sie uns
einmal noch beim thema corona und der
frage eines möglichen lockt downs
bleiben wir sehen die inzidenz zahlen
wir sehen die hospitalisierung quoten
und es gibt ein brief über den wir
gestern bereits hier in der sendung
gesprochen haben auch auf bild de und in
der bild zeitung berichten aus dem
finanzministerium der geht an den chef
des haushaltsausschusses und darin wird
nochmal eine weitere summe gefordert für
die messe herstellung das ganze messe
gewerbe es geht um 150 millionen
zusätzliche hilfen mit der begründung
dass man ja im herbst wieder ein
ansteigen des instituts und ansteckung
in einer ansteckung entwicklung wieder
hat also deutet alles darauf hin dass
ist neue einschränkungen gibt dass auch
die bundesregierung möglicherweise neue
einschränkungen für einige bereiche in
deutschland plant und war in dieses
papier auf das sie da dekorieren das
beinhaltet die überbrückungshilfe drei
die werden herbst und winter fortsetzen
weil wir ein klares signal gegeben haben
auch heute in der kabinettssitzung wir
lassen auch im herbst und winter wärme
zum beispiel ein problem dass er nicht
mit unseren infektionszahlen
zusammenhängt aber viele lieferketten
auch aus asien funktionieren nicht
richtig und machen der deutschen
wirtschaft probleme haben wir drei dinge
besprochen besprochen die
überbrückungshilfe 3 wird fortgesetzt
unternehmen können sich auch im herbst
und winter auf unsere unterstützung
zählen das kurzarbeitergeld wird bis
jahresende auch fortgesetzt
das heißt auch die arbeitnehmer haben
sicherheit wenn ein betrieb nicht
bearbeitet und die pflege unterstützung
die setzen wir auch fort also drei
wichtige maßnahmen trotzdem noch mal die
frage weil in dem brief explizit von
steigenden inzidenz zahlen und
steigenden infektionszahlen gesprochen
wird also droht da einer lockten anders
gefragt können sie versprechen als
kanzleramtsminister der sicherlich noch
ein paar monate im amt bleiben wird auch
über die bundestagswahl erst mal hinaus
können sie versprechen dass es kein und
garantieren dass es keinen herbst
lockdown geben wird also wir haben es ja
habe ich gerade gesagt werden so dass
mit der delta variante zu tun wo unsere
impfstoffe gut wirken deshalb sagt das
robert-koch-institut sehr klar dass die
geimpften am infektionsgeschehen keinen
relevanten anteil mehr haben momentan
und auch die berichte die wir haben über
infektionen bei geimpften sind in aller
regel symptomlos oder sehr symptom arm
das heißt das rechtfertigt keine
einschränkenden maßnahmen und deshalb
haben wir jetzt sagt wir schauen auf die
zahl der menschen in krankenhäusern die
es momentan auf einem
vertretbaren niveau und solange wir
nicht eine belastungssituation in den
krankenhäusern haben wird es auch keine
weitergehenden beschränkungen geben und
schon gar nicht für geimpfte und gené
heißt aber locker und nicht
ausgeschlossen nein das heißt es nicht
sondern wenn geimpfte und genesen am
infektionsgeschehen nicht teilnehmen
gibt es keinen grund irgendetwas für die
zu beschränken
[Musik]